two things you have the national culture
of countries of regions and you have the
company culture two different things
we're gonna change the national culture
we can't do it and the beauty of the
world is that people are different so
you go to China they dress differently
their pastime is different their food is
different they have landmarks that are
different that's so beautiful then you
go to India you go to Brazil go to
Belgium go to Germany you have to Canada
go to the US even in the same country
different regions
that's all beautiful that's why the
world is so interesting and one thing we
said from the very beginning is that if
you join our company that's we called
the ten principles one dream to own
people seven on culture
ten in good and bad times they don't
change those are the principles so if
you like them great we're not going to
change them and that causes turnover yes
but fine because it takes 20 years 30
years a lifetime to get the fabric to to
be one a strong one it can destroy that
by studying being flexible and starting
believing things you go to Korea and
people say oh no even printer here is
different that's all idea of targets and
compensation for example tell you when
we came to the US because we believed in
the ownership our long-term incentive
okay it's 5-year vest so for you to get
the shares it's a five-year vesting
period the company we acquired in the US
was three years
given that the one-third would rest in
the first year the second third in the
second the third the third we said
forget it
that's that short term that's not long
term call it something else if you're
gonna be here for 30 years what's five
years ours is five sometimes ten years
cliff so if you live for years 11 months
zero it's five years and a lot of people
left because of that for example I
travel commercial and yes because I
travel to Russia China India
all that it in a way one could picture
as a waste of time but that's important
for the culture because then when I ask
her people guys we're in a tough year we
need you guys to to buckle up and to
really stretch things and really give
your best because it's a tough year and
find non-working money so we can invest
behind the work your money I can say it
because I travel commercial I stay in
the same hotel as everybody stays they
stay in the same hotel as all I do I eat
the same thing they eat everything's the
same
I make more money than they do we're not
socialists okay no but on the silly
things we hate anything that's a status
symbol we think that destroys the whole
idea of a group an engaged group so I
don't have a company car I don't have a
driver I don't have an office I don't
have a jet I'm just like all my
colleagues and yes it takes a toll but
it's worth for the culture which is much
bigger and the culture is the one that
gives us the performance which I'm here
for then it's a full circle but again
this I give national culture so what
Japan is different but if you Japanese
call like want to join a company you
have to buy into this concepts and by
the way what we say is that you have to
have a big dream surround yourself with
the best people can find and create an
environment where they stay look at my
Phelps he had the same idea he wanted to
have eight gold medals why eight all of
us would be happy with one you wanted
eight dream he surrounded himself with
the best people he could find coaches
exercise people everything in he own the
process here's not being forced to do it
he was doing this and during his
birthday Christmas Day New Year's
because you wanted so the prince was
applied to any good student here at the
GSP to any good athletes and we believe
to the company too so we're not asking
anything that's out of the ordinary it's
all common sense but because it's common
sense people don't talk about it they
take it for granted and that's why it
doesn't work that's diluted so one
company one culture never buy into the
situation enough here
doesn't work now we've tried before
trust me it doesn't work don't buy it
because then if cultures to do a
performance and you dilute it your
performance will suffer and as a leader
again you're there to generate results
with the people do it the right way